hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast a proposed fee no typing
method for human innate lymphoid cells
ilcs using flow cytometry and Julie
O'Rourke of labyrinths and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth and
sponsored by Beckman Coulter life
sciences Beckman Coulter develops
manufactures and markets products that
simplify automate and innovate complex
biomedical testing more than 275,000
Beckman culture systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences
laboratories on seven continents for
more than 80 years Beckman cultures
products have been making a difference
in people's lives
by improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
patient health and delivering trusted
solutions for research and discovery for
more information please visit Beckman
Coulter comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on a screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Oliver
Zhang dr. Zhang works at Beckman culture
at emerging market Europe Asia India as
a flow cytometry marketing manager and
also as an application scientist he
belongs to both teams to get support and
scientific expertise to customers and
also internally he is specialized in
immunology and hematology of human and
mouse model systems before joining
Beckman Coulter he completed a PhD in
power
Southern University he worked at the in
some unit in Paris 13 dopamine hop
University and obvious and hospital for
flow cytometry previously he worked on
Mouse dendritic cells and regulatory
t-cells in Mouse autoimmunity another
part of his PhD was done on human
rheumatoid arthritis patients
he is molecular biology to understand
the role of toll-like receptors single
nucleotide polymorphisms in disease
progression is now involved in the
development of multi color panels for
food for flow cytometry research
clinical research and routine analysis i
will now turn it over to dr. Zhang for
his presentation Thank You Julie for
this introduction so today I want to
take your fertility to be on this
webinar to talk to you about the human
eye Nadine for itself and a proposed
method to phenotype them using flow
cytometry so first of all I want to say
that all of these presentation is for
research use on me and even in
psychotics
is a psychometric that is probably
searched only not for using diagnostic
procedure so before talking properly
about human I'm making police's I want
to present you or remind you depends
about the human system this women system
is basically divided into island an
adaptive compartment and inside these
two compartment you have different self
so we can see different set on the left
of the slide the outer phagocyte cells
monocytes macrophages dendritic cells
but you have also mast cells
granulocytes such as electrophile you
can fry pacifier and we can also me the
natural killer cell and this natural
killer cells are rich to Island in
result and we'll talk about this after
and we have also not only cells but also
for the ions such as
projects so on the right of the slide
you have adaptive compartment that is
composed mostly by P cells and the
differentiation from B cells that
generate the humoral immunity secreting
antibodies and T cells cd4 and cd8
cellular immunity and they will protium
between the two you have cells react as
I met cells and also able to create
other team in the restaurant are the NKT
cells and the Gamma Delta at season so
during an infection by pathogens at the
beginning if you are looking at
intensity versus time you have the eye
lighting and responses once the with the
blue narrow gear you have a pathogens
load so Molina at the beginning you have
a proliferation of the pathogens but you
are the elect phase I like to read
responses that is developing this I met
in references provide help to adaptive
immune responses in which the narrow web
is the elements of B cells and T cells
that are increasing these infections as
soon as these cells are open up grab the
pathogen levels are pulling it down and
you have a control phase in which
students playing to control adaptive
immune cells to avoid toxicity from the
body and to immortal immunity for
example and then the load of adaptive
cells is going down but not p0 that was
at the beginning and you have a load
that is constituting a memory for you
Indian system and you have the memory
store adaptive in themselves if you are
next time in front of the same type of
genes then the West Point's is would be
quicker than the previous one so we are
not focusing on innate immune cells so I
Nathan places ourselves from the inot
compartment then have the lymphocyte
morphology and they are not expressing
recombination activating genes so they
are not able to make receptor we
arrangements such as the B cells and T
cells with TCR and BCR so I get pimply
cells composed about about natural
killer cells lymphoid tissue and use of
self-support
FC high and in this family the line age
negative PI Network cells they all came
from ID to positive practice or an IP to
this in a liter of DNA binding that
prevent them differentiate into adaptive
immune cells so the classification was
made in 2013 it was made on the site
cytokine secretion so coming from the ID
to positive I see precursor depending of
cytokine and activation of different
transcription factor you have different
Island exams the first one the first
group will be electrically cells warm
that create internal in gamma and this
group is composed about with NK cells
and innate immune cells one then you
have the second book that is computed
about I net in point cells to that
secret I four and five and is salty and
then the last one is the I make new
products and number three that is
composed about lymphoid tissue inducer
and I net memory cells 3 that secret I
17 and I'm 22 so if you look at some
markers that are expressed by inside
excellent point cell you can classify in
3 groups with their different cells that
are inside the 3 groups and what you can
see here that there are whole excepting
NK cells negative online agent rocker
they all expressed cd45
such as classical lymphocyte Zhen
Express also cd16 one for all of the
cell more or less then you ever saw some
up and hippies that are expressed such
as NK p 44 and 46
then they are all positive for the city
1 to 7 that would be very interesting to
use for Kentucky for sure and you have
the CRT and shoe that is specific for I
met in prison cells - and some older
marker classical marker are more or less
Express or negative search under C for
example so as a consequence of that you
can identify different kind of model
such as a line H you see he went to 7
the endgame p2 cd16 1 CL th - silly 45 C
D 56 and CD 117 - sick hunt
so the classical piano type but you can
see in the different world or
publication all coming on lymphocyte
game then we are looking at like a h-
nc-17 and all of these ionic appraisal
are positive for this marker accepting
inpatient and we have a beautiful
cluster here that is positive for us to
move on to seven not negative for the
language after that song
Valentina the city one six one positive
cells and they look into with CMT HP
with the CD one one sorry dot plot by
example and what we can result here in
green with the I little princess type
two that are positive for the CRT
attitude then if you look at dawn I met
him for it's a substitute you lose with
a CD 1 1 7 and mkp 44 and then you can
reserve the I kneel in places that are
double negative in red and then to
population of electric rates l3 positive
for mkp classically code I mental
results 3 NK n p+ the NCR positive and
then the NCR negative that are I say 3
and 0 negative so remember these three
kind of phenotype that are going to
begin doing this presentation so I left
in point cells are also a study in
others so there are different groups in
this
in this field that are looking at pilot
employed cells in tonsils in Gertz and
billion but also in lame inflamed last
nizam point and no meat turnovers but
also in the skin in different kind of
diseases and we will talk about after
but also in the screen to look at human
potential on piloting for itself such as
helped to create adaptive in the
restaurants and then infinite instead of
some portion so what is the disability
to distribution of I met in brain cells
in guilty human so I mean I like
employee cells world are present in
peripheral blood with anybody low
amounts and there are mainly present at
lamina propria for different organs the
inet lymphoid cells to our present also
in the blood and this is the micro type
of I met employed cells in the blood but
they are also present in the skin I need
lamprey cells three are present also in
the blood but in the scheme in the
spleen and the finest in the tonsil in
the gut and even in the bone marrow for
an instability cells one of these cells
are present naturally in the body to
create some tissue reparation to create
some investments and pay other cells and
to be present for pathogens infection so
also cells important in some disease so
some work was made and it seems up I see
one secret leader from the gamma
improving the chronic disease that is
important in releasing from the girls
then we also to I get employee cells
truly as a is sick rating is 17 also
important that from disease then if you
look at I let me polish cells too
because of the secretion of our 5 in 5
13 they could stimulate mast cells and
l05 and recruit them and the different
organs in a particular manatees for
example but also in life
/ sensitivity finally I let me point
three are also involved in get cancer
and sorry artists security I I'm 22 and
then you have also a recent paper sorry
one year ago that was monitoring of
anything for itself in the context of
actually mail in Kenya after illusion a
silly 24 injection and what they what
they did is looking at I'll identify
cells three and they saw a link between
the better outcome and the presence of
NZ and zr+
I met in points as three cells so the
purple of this world was to create an
easy panel and the methodology to
phenotype peripheral I met lymphoid
cells this panel could be used on
several instruments configuration from
the markets meaning the most the most
present on the markets or three legs or
a coral for example this panel should be
a basis for potential addition of
automata Hulu dance proliferation or to
look at activation and the idea was to
have a global prosecutor in DC for
stored organization for multi-subject
apples what are the difficulties are
phenotyping are knitting fully cells in
fact we don't need no no really when
this population in normal but also in
diseases and this population expressed
some team antigen and some continued
express markers or to take care of this
tournament because they are not very
threatened we are in the wrong element
analysis domain and atom and we will
propose something to look if we are
looking at what is really important so
before the probability panel we take
care about the importance of still of
spreading matrix that was published from
donor and we need on the Sacramento
using silver stain and we will please
say your say ourselves because as as it
was described depends as you can see
here the spreading is the same if you
lose the beans themselves so the problem
coming from mythical or approach will be
very tried before the development to
know if your combination create or not
some spreading that could abort that to
blind you if you are looking at some
population and the papers are looking at
the difference between the 50% speed
means percentage and the 84% deals are
spreading into the y-axis in this case
looking at the difference if you are
spread the distance is higher and the
predicting compared to the negative one
zero this spreading is dependent also
about the difference in medium from
positive and negative in the primary
shining but why it is so important so
here you have an example that was quite
easy it's a six twelve are spending on
the left you have a Qi Lang pattern that
was making is the combination of the
bottom and just little big the city
three to another color you can see that
we lose very very don't feel sorry for
that we in a very high manner we do with
every single other tier X so it means
that just moving one on T bodies which
create a very bad staining and you lose
some important sense that's why it's
important to take care of this when you
are developing some mythical or paddling
or cytometry so as we said there is not
well-known population numbered and in
disease and we had deal Express and
region but also continue expression
marker so we need to classify the
difference marker into primary teacher
such are the cd45 and sydney one two
seven our door and extras like polka
cells then you have a secondary and
tertiary antigen that continues for
canary and pendulum from there we're
teaching the name of that is to avoid
these two situation where you have a
spreading of the blue population into a
violet one that can blind you and please
limit your capacity to detect in the
high sensitive sensitivity manner the
sailing from the violet population and
the other one is from the spanning from
another population into another one that
we mix population and create false
result so we need to avoid this
situation for example here the bright
violet 650 and you have a strand and you
spread even if you have a low percentage
of compensation only 14.5 percent of
compensation but you have a hue is
straight from the politic correlation
into the several directional we need to
run the cave of limitation into
detection of the pieces flag marker in
this case nevertheless as we can see on
the right the pigeon is spreading into
the easily channels but is well known it
is well shown by the black population
p.m. but what you can see is that we
have a green area meaning that you can
use the piggy
even if you are using a low express
matter in the ECE because if you're
sailing or expression of the marker is
very low who can say that the pill is
not spreading into the other channel so
you can do it with both so this is an
example of a compensation matrix and you
have the percentage the compensation
presentation inside but you have also
colors and here the colors are showing
you the straining of a positive marker
into other channel for example me we are
the preceding
you'll see p-side 5.5 with a huge amount
of strain into the blue 750 and include
the red 710 channel so it means that if
you are using
news from marker
some difficulties into these two
channels so as a consequence it will
remove the the compensation presentation
the other cliff map a little is to
appreciate the different dyes we now
treat the different channels on the
column and what okay
identify pins up the Fiji is not
spreading in any channels but you can
also see that the blue 525 channels is
untouched by all the time so using this
we are able to see that the blue five to
five channel means then touch the PD
channel is also quite touch the be 450
is also been touched by the order and
also the three 540 channels so we can
select four channels to get high
sensitivity and remember that for
example here you have a PC an extra 300
750 so this time is spreading into the
classical a PC channel but also include
the Alexa fluor salamanca channels works
if you are using a low express marker
using this dies then this creates these
dyes as a totally silence so allow you
to avoid problems of straining so
dependent design was made considering
the SSM of the instrument the brightness
of the dark the spillover of the
different dyes and expression pattern of
the cell so we choose the cd45 in the
Putnam
because Pat Boone was described are
totally silent so since our cursor will
express that you will have very much
because the Pacific book is science so
it doesn't generate some perturbation in
different channels then we move on to CD
1 to 7 and we decided to you leave in
the ABC Alexa fluor hundred and seven
and fifty sorry because this 2 to 7 is a
deal give me expressive the cells and
the dyes is enough price to see the
positive and negative
remember that all of their expenses even
want to sell then we decided to put this
year
co-op th-th - sorry into pizza because
if it's instument in touch so we will
have the food sensitivity look at this
marker in this channel and we know that
it could be expressed a little bit but
it could be also modulated then we
innately 44 that is more or less dimly
Express and because n KP 44 positive
cells are not very frequent we need to
be sure that we have a vintage channel
with very bright markers or a cross
shows in that MPE then we have the city
197 that was should children in beat me
sci-fi about five because Psi Phi
Fraternity is a very bright signal and
we know that the city one one seven is
expressed from the deal - moon strong so
we need to be able to carefully
detecting the different level of
expression of this marker then we have
the city one six one that is explained
by all of them I met them for itself and
the expression could be in tourniquet
too strong so we need to use all three
ties the priests I tried is privatized
commercial design doc Barker and even if
we have spreading of the PSI seven into
the APC Alex some three or 750 channel
because all of them sell will be
positive positive one to seven we can
don't care about city want to see the
one six one spreading it with the
Chilean people welding up one of the
cells are expressing this is equal to
seven channels so no problem at all we
can work with this writing then we
decided to put the line age in place pc
channel because we want to let them the
best separation between the I network
played cells of non negative for line
age and all the other cells that could
contaminate the electric point cells
cloud by the hand we will for sure use a
dead cell marker to eliminate some
facts that could come from their selves
so that one the combination we decided
to use and that man I'm working with
some different instrument but because we
are the rare event analogies are
definitely should values that was you
miss ecology software and all the side
effects because they allow you to go up
to 30,000 event by second and they move
slow by anyone access file more than ten
millions and because of the frequency of
animal preserve we need to have this
possibility to have a lot of data if we
want to have a good CV because just to
be benign
the standard deviation is the square
root of n where n is the total number of
event you are looking at and the CV is
100 divided by by SC so it means that if
you want the CV that is good for example
10 you need at least 100 events in to
indicate that you are looking at so if
you are not having enough ellipse you
see this going down such as 44
particular form in 6 event in the
indicate so remember if you want to make
that you'll need to have a good feel
because you can concentrate your samples
and you have to store on more than more
than warm 2 million to route laser data
of CV so the white blood cells for total
mass make and the idea of the white
blood cells what the problem was because
if you want to standardize something you
need to promote any human relation
introduction meaning that the samples
are of better quality if you have less
manipulation of the samples and I
strongly suggest you to look at this
letter from marine Palin group they
discuss with ordered matter
we propose a consumption April to be
standardized minion system from a piping
and you propose to do
MZ because sometimes we need to do it
but they really discussion this for me
because you know you have because of
human viability and prosecutor you
increase the punishment so it's
difficult to standardize the result so
if I hear once we start with a fresh one
word what mark sorry and because of low
frequencies I met with point sales we
need a huge amount of blood so the idea
was to deliver on the blob you have then
realizing advertising with analytics our
team lysis solution to pre-sales
messaging Express at the modern level
and then direct laptop on rush you spend
the balance and fill this until this
daily you just realized when you wash
and you go to psychomat this one the
first protocol but because some people
want to use some PDF series that came
from previous storage so we need to make
a protocol for billions he also and
sometimes we have no shorts so losing
this total sample so we argue the final
protocol so let's make the protocol on
your shoes for you and as you realizing
the file you need to be very careful
when you're collecting blu-ray or PBMC
and then you need to wash at least two
times and then maybe you have to count
yourselves before water stain so
definitely you can remove cells and it
makes a protocol lobular and because
this is some human manipulation we bring
you some variability into your text so
nevertheless it will be done edna crops
so after this we have one wash and we'll
have to decide the batter so just a
quick remark about different dial you
can use sometimes you can use some
antibodies that create nonspecific
binding so you need to optimize so here
you have a beautiful example comparing
one on z bodies in a bcl-xl flan where
it's 7 PP and you will make if I don't
form or
company for example and first of all you
can say that we have a better brightness
and I think it's honest I hear you have
nonspecific binding so it is not very
good if you're if you want good data so
that's why we decided to shoot the APC
at least a few hundred and fifty dollars
and here you have the result that I've
already shown and as I said before
because this marker CD one to seven
we still me express you don't have any
spread of this population into the
language marketer so you don't have any
mixture of these final employed cell
population into the line H so we decided
to make it on side effects and side
effects are for me the possibility to
calculate the staining X because when
you are developing a particular panel
you need to titrate your antibodies so
in this case it's a true example on CD 3
for example
so psychopaths are finding the
possibility to launch on directly into
your topic or the same index formulae so
you have the result directly here the
same index is present on your table and
we can export all of that for your
sample then you'll get your CSV file and
what you can see in your table you have
the volume of your antibodies or we go
until this quantity then you have your
saline index here and you have the
percentage of positive cells then we can
improve directly your pistol back to
look at the best staining index and to
verify also that we don't yourselves so
that the positive cells are still the
same even at low concentration of your
optimum ease then we leave here you have
some result for cd16 one in psi seven
and we use at the top the titration at
the top so we get the best ending index
and for an example for silly object will
exceed we do the second one
so remind just that we have a better say
index and we want to monitor also that
percentage a positive cell is still the
same
then we go to the site flex and you need
to calculate your compensation so that's
quite easily click on file then click on
new compensation the sustain generate
you or window directly here and you can
pick different to perhaps or in for
example I click everything and then I
understand cell and palisade means
because one cycle friends a good point
is that you can have a make sure meaning
that we can say the Treasury is made on
this because co2 actually is very low
and if you would have a stroke for
example rocker here the city 45 is my
own selves because city 45 is higher
than the set the pit stain so we want to
lose the best positive signal that's why
you in South of France they reportedly
customers to use and stay sell rock
stately and to program with silver same
here and you say link will be made on
Billy and on cell as well then it create
for you the list and then once you
approve your everything you just click
on compensation calculation and it is
done the good point of this panel is
that one cycle tracks you can have this
free slot switch channels that you can
limit if you want to have others also
natural if you want to ask different
question
doing I'm making three sets Phillip ID
so during the process calculation you
what you can see here is only the
spillover from please into the peel
channel that is normal and if you
haven't worked on this situation because
the psychopath is using clinical buys
meaning that we have seven decades to
make your study if we only had one
decade and it's not over out of sale and
you know because it's unsafe because we
have seven decades so everything intro
is on scale so it's not a problem you
don't have to keep it as a voltage or
something like this then you have to
save the compensation so here you have
different number we will talk about
these so you can save as a compensation
file on your hard drive but you can
store also leads
the library the good thing with library
is that you can keep every single state
except one if you need to replace one
and the software will manage the
compensation with a newly added so you
just have to pick another one
maybe you can change from the tund and
by for example sometimes your comments
are strongly difference so if you just
change the tandem you can bring it
directly into your system and don't care
about recalculating ever see so we will
have to import on your experiment so
find new experiment you make a little
princess Emily water compensation and on
side effects it will ask you something
what do you want to do with your matrix
and the good things from that world of
recycle meter is that you can import
compensation matrix same day okay we can
only import compensation or you can
import compensation matrix and transform
them or convert them on the children
again you're using price break cells
fellow typing so it means that because
of the detectors that are inside that
was cytometer no psycho clicks that is
not using photomultiplier tube many more
but avalanche photodiodes that are
completely different from pnts
you can make it meaning that you can
change the day it will not just directly
for you the compensation matrix so we
open these are you can see in point of
view we have some highly value or grows
and 100 persons so how we could manage
that so we can import a compensation
with the high value and because this
value is not very classical anyway you
can change directly to gain in your
acquisition setting and it will
calculate and manage directly it for you
and you have the same result with other
value of compensation
what does it change on the side effects
so and they'll talk you have the the
result from t-cells we see a 27mpg born
in the example here we can resolve for
different population at least and this
was named with more
a compensation of the PSI fiber tied
into the psi seven and if you just
decrease the gain of the PSI seven you
decrease the value of the percentage
here and on the right you have the same
example the same dude that one that one
supplier with different game with an
automatically adjusting compensation
matrix for you and as you can see is
there is not a strong differences people
do maybe then the position of the same
that is number because we decrease the
game of the penis I serve each others
but the data Australia is saying that's
a good point of this technology so doing
project compensation you can build it on
your setting okay then you just have to
throw your template so just here I show
you some example and you have the
possibility to just click to show your
different parameters then if rule to
apply again you just left-click on the
ribbon and show your case then this
sailing we are focusing on cd45 positive
cell then from the city one two seven
positive cell line age negative cells
and then we have the top blocks that are
interesting to or sorry to monitor the
different population of high level
concepts so so I met really sets to that
are c16 or volatility are positive and
then you have the different population
of my next lymphoid cells one double
negative here and I met in place in exam
three more or less 30 teams or nkp okay
so because we want to be very accurate
in the positioning of the different age
we we align the fluorescence -1 tombs
and here you have the result on the plus
or minus one to four city want to Sarah
then we realize is the CRT extremely
fluorescence minus 1/2 and here you have
the result of this and we said carefully
because then we are the same for the
cd16 one and then for Lisa T 1 1 7 here
you have the result of the full stage
with the same gate partition and as you
can see here we don't have to move the
gate and you have the population inside
in the psycho facts you can show you
that now if you want to make a meeting
lab by the doctor properly so you can
compare the fluorescence - want to read
for example here and the full same in
black and you can populate the results
to prove that you correctly set the gate
and you can see the result for the
different super overlay of the different
persons - virtue and the for sale then
you have the results here so in inside
of flex you have the Radiological table
and then you have a table here but give
you the result so you have the desert
area with the concentration also so for
this painting we have the result and we
have the concentration on the different
ionic cells population that is expressed
by events by micron stir this
concentration is saved on the body so
you don't need to have counting beats
determine the concentration here and
here you have the result of the total a
little point cells population so it was
2.67 cells 5 micrometers and B to
convert that into literals you have the
laser here we have to know that this
result total agreement with the paper
from abroad inclusive of a protein
meaning that the job was done so what
about the planet so sometimes he comes
up to spill out or you can say that okay
we have some time and died to create
some Valentin T's and cetera so here you
have the results at the top with
compensation and you have the gate the
gate at work that we are set and on the
bottom you have the the
without any compensation and as you can
see here were very very few
contamination of the different gait
meaning that the pan and the combination
is highly reduced even if you have some
viability in the Talmud so here you have
the result that was made on the daggers
that was made on PBMCs and in these we
use the dead cell marker to remove the
dead said the dead cells and we have in
the city
56 in PCB and you can resolve very
bright me here the city 56 positive
population that were expressed by
electrically cells 3 and the islet in
princess one population what about the
results on white blood cells
so here you have the resin that was mega
McDaniels on white blood cells aliens
after we will delete objects without
focusing on voluntary ourselves and you
can think about where are the
granulocytes
not the most important cell from the
blood which is in what run blood and in
this case because we don't want to save
the result for the granular site we
decided to create a light 8 and which
generates you the possibility to store
only what is on the mononuclear cells so
it's a little you'll remove yourselves
that are more interesting and as you can
see here we can resolve the same in the
same way to different population of
electrolytic cells I mention princess to
electing princess wrong and I Nathan
playsets 3 so this is the result that is
highly comparable with the PBMC meaning
that we could save time and increase the
standardization of the portion you know
if you are using one blood cells so a
question came is okay what about the
battlefield that will be see on tht
positive cells also and click
contaminate your mononucleosis gay but
because of the line edge as you can see
the population
was a fraud gray you can see that the
city 1 2 3 was enough to remove all of
the cells and as you can see on the city
45 versus SSC the beautiful red alert of
the different population of I met
lymphoid cells we made that didn't have
any contamination of the butterflies
okay so one of these was made using
manual dish but because we want to make
it was less supervised as possible to
increase employee any subjectivity of
people analyzing the psychometric data
they decided to make and tend to be more
different from Beckman filter from him
we provided we decided to inject the
result of FCS fry into our software and
we decided to do with the auto gate
algorithm that is June in the throne
density package and here you may have an
automatically set up the gates so
without any human intervention here and
what we can see with that indeed it
works very well and the name of that was
to compare the result of manual gating
at the bottom here versus automatic
gating without any supervision of you
mind and if you look for example at I
let me reset 3 and C are positive we
have
0.9 percent of the power gate and if you
look at the data from the automatic
changing here we are all point almost
page that is very close and we count
nine events
automatically and we count seven events
meaning that we are highly accurate in
manual also but also in the open right
way the ante automatically it is working
that well another I mean goal of this is
to use negative and supervised analysis
using some algorithms at crystallize
population so
we T SME and we're using our software
and the t-sne is a choc-ice stochastic
neighborhood and baby and here you have
the results of the automatic clustering
of the software and what we can see here
is that inside the island in 20 cents -
you have at least three clusters of
computation and we are not may be aware
of this but maybe in some aspect looking
at every dimension of saying we can have
maybe much more population that we are
finding path we have also some we have
say unknown but maybe are some
contamination of some dates because as
we saw previously the island willfully
sells wrong are not released a
specifically by marker at least by cd45
in city 2007 may be seeing one six one
but the other one ignorant not
positively expressed by it also may be
inside this population there is
something different and this approach
could generate some new populations are
normal to this designer people accept
wrong so this is maybe the next step so
I'm going to talk about maybe sorry for
that about the future sorrow
what about new I hated presence
population some more and more now
discussing about using you know to 7
negative population and okay we need to
look into this population more in detail
now and that's why some people want to
add activation repairs or charges such
as a CD 69 but also chemical receptor
marker to know where they are going
because we are looking at the population
into the blood but for sure they are not
doing something in the webs armor they
are only traveling but without they're
going so using some different chemical
marker or something maybe we can have an
answer to this and maybe from
pharmaceutical point of view because of
the district
I'm making police cells in tissue and
because of the potential role in disease
but also in specific in restaurants
health it could be very interesting to
understand how we could manipulate some
cells in vivo to maybe decrease the
pathologies or prevents the pathologies
development so maybe this is the future
of such tank of population so just to
conclude here as you may understand
identical cells are under the scope in
immunology there are clearly linked to
disease so we decided to have a simple
rub use and panel Pro cytometry but also
a methodology that can help the
standardization of it's a stereotyping
and this first panel could be used on
classic down flow cytometry from the
market such as external law such as
Maxwell or something like this and even
from Batman side the middle portion and
you could look at activation using using
the CD 69 in ECG channel for example
Sikaflex
my hope is definitely we choose to look
into this detail and very good partner
to do that because of the speed and
because of the capacity to store a lot
of minutes and as we we saw what she is
find that will be generated maybe could
be made look into details with other
software and algorithm to know if we
could look at different aspect of the
phenotyping
so just to finish I want to say thank
you in technical term connects so people
from the development compartments are
enemies but also can what you doing for
this help into automatic
clustering analysis on this stereotyping
or so the team that provide me some
reagent
and the psychometric for sure so back to
you Judy and I'm open for questions
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can there with me one second I see
questions are coming in and in a second
before they come through our system okay
someone says hi Oliver have you looked
for EM cr+
I lc3 and NCR negative I lc3 in
peripheral blood so good question thank
you for instructions or definitely yes
it's on PBMC and onward rod so maybe I
can go back to the slide so here you
have the result form for right $0.01 and
as you can see on the right bottom you
have three dots or me for this
population so technically it is very
very feelings at least for normal or
drug and it was the same for pmc here
you can see that we have very very few
guns but because of the publication that
we are making on this topic we are sure
that this is the position of the cells
that's why we believe in this result but
yeah to see these
these are very long so we need to take
care about this population back to you
how precisely do the ILC panels propose
surrogates surface markers predict the
expected or postulated secretory
phenotype the question people basic I
mean if you look at the publication that
were made they decided to create the
classification on the I met in to exist
operation and we are bringing back to
this slide
okay here we we see that this I little
bristles are separating this population
this psychic I'm sorry and this was made
regarding from sowing and looking at via
the pattern here so they verify that
this expressed marker appear we're in a
lead to the potential of the situation
of the different cytokine so yes we
could be confident with the secretion
capacity of the cells blood in what well
maybe they are not going to secrete this
because they don't have any signal to do
it so it seems that this phenotype I'll
link to these capacities but in what
blood maybe is I'm not going to do it
naturally so it means a generate but you
need to sort the cells and look into
individual which they are setting up or
not but you can also look at the
transcription factor or events to verify
that it is in agreement means that of a
publication that was made so back to the
included sorry
there seems to be a reluctance to
include intracytoplasmic wasting
cytokine expression pattern into the
panel why it is so I didn't get the
question sure
there seems to be a reluctance to
include interest cytoplasmic restain
cytokine expression pattern into the
panel
why okay yes maybe I get it so if I
understand well it is possible to create
fellow typing and looking at the
capacity situation in France in Raleigh
nevertheless sees this is possible but
depending on the protocol you have you
have a less resolution or Rembrandt from
teaching so because some guinea express
20 genes
we must picture this and the second
approach is that you need to standardize
also the blocking step of the separation
and it's human step so you can do it
definitely I will say yes you can do it
with eternity we didn't do this but we
because we want to make it easy at the
beginning to look at the frequencies in
the different disease on what Gordon and
PDM see so we can think about this and
make it on leniency or block therapy
depends we need to think about this and
if you just create the manipulation
longer so it will create maybe somebody
abilities and some hard work for people
but positive definite if I go back to
unity
come you look for transcription factor
characteristics for ILC one in
parentheses t-bet ILC two gata3
ILC 3r orgt sorry five mispronounced yes
so the answer is very easy so at this
moment not I know that some people from
the R&D group are looking into that and
yes they are going to look to see how
some classical transcription factor such
as exhibit the gate a tree but ROTC is
still set context but they are working
on that but unity how do you
differentiate between NK cells and il
series so I suppose I guess in the in
the panel so we are looking at the lead
role of floor psychometric panel so we
decided in the line age to have CD 94
marker such as it was described in
different papers so all of the in cases
are not going into the line age package
language sound and we don't have any
contamination by NK cells due to this
specific expression of this marker
have you developed any panel to identify
ILC from non-human primate blood samples
or have any references
good question very good points at the
moment no we we focused on Norma
because this is the main I mean
application of potential pharmaceutical
company I mean they are developing some
treatments and yeah maybe maybe we need
to feel about these non-human primates
sailing that at the moment we didn't do
anything so so I would say that maybe we
are thinking odd but we are not doing
nothing at the minute I would once again
like to thank dr. Oliver Jean for his
presentation do you have any final
comments for us today
yeah I am so I hope that this
presentation will help you to create
some enacting for itself a no typing if
you have any question or comment or
something you have my email address or
feel free feel free to ask me and I will
be very pleased to answer to that and I
wish you to all of you a very nice
Christmas and we will see you maybe next
year and I wish you the best for the
next year thank you
I'd also like to thank our sponsor
Beckman Coulter Lifesciences for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July 18 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
Ford that announcements your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
see you next time goodbye